[Music]
i've written two
fiction short stories
which is not many but two in the last
few weeks
and the first was really easy for me to
complete which i was surprised by but it
was it was almost entirely based on
real events so the first 75 percent was
basically
taking the the
true events and sort of putting them in
a different wardrobe but it came out
very easily
and then i had to fuss with it and have
a few cups of coffee to figure out the
rest but in in the process of a few
hours i was able to write a two-page
short story very short
and then i decided well let me try
something that's really
more from the
imaginary realm and this this proved to
be i think going to the deep end of the
pool without my floaties on my arms
maybe a little too early and uh and i
got into this story that i'm
that i've been working on and i'm five
six pages in and i'm just like where is
this going i have no [ __ ] idea how to
wrap this up what's the point of it so
all these voices
my specific question is
if i don't know where it's going and i
have no idea what to do and therefore
i'm even more prone to putting off the
writing for polishing my tennis shoes or
fixing the doorknob or whatever excuse i
can come up with
would you
personally for you or your students just
start writing anything at all to get the
hands moving even if it's not related to
the story in other words if you're
halfway through
some larger project but you really don't
know what to do will you just write on
something that's completely unrelated
well i believe that the people and the
material know who they are and what they
do
and that they need to trust that you're
a reliable narrator
and this brings me to a whole thing that
i could do an hour on which is that if
you grew up around alcoholics or the
mentally ill the first thing you agree
to is to not to see what's going on
right because it makes them so unhappy
if you notice so you agree you for your
whole life you just agree not to see
what's going on and so you lose the
ability to trust yourself as the
narrator of your own
story
and so
the material and the characters
will
give you themselves and their actions
as they trust you
to get it right
and so for me that's why i really
believe in the quiet and the silence and
i can i taught my fifth the
five-year-olds in this writing workshop
close your eyes there's a screen on the
back of your eyes can you see the people
what can you tell me about them so you
can get very quiet and close your eyes
and go inward and then you can ask the
people you can ask the characters what
were you thinking then
what did you feel your choices were
why were you not willing
to just say what was true and that you
had the answer they were looking for you
had the missing purse or you had
whatever you can ask them
tell me something about you and
what do you think in this circumstance
would be plaguing you here's the thing
with the story you might want to ask
yourself what's at stake like you're
trying to get to know these characters
better you can write it 20 pages on a
tim i'm promising you this you can write
a 20-page short story you can take out
eight pages
and then you can send me the 12 and i'll
edit it for you but the thing is that
something has to be at stake so what is
you ask yourself and your characters
what do they love most in the world what
are they at risk of losing
if they're not at risk there's no story
there it could be a child it could be
their sobriety it could be
their life but what what do they stand
to lose
so ask them and you can look at them
maybe there's two or three main
characters and you ask them what
couldn't you lose and then you put some
pressure on that where that could be at
risk and then you can see
how they in fact respond do they run
do they put their fingers in their ears
and go la la la la la do they drink only
you know
and these people inside of you know and
you can ask them but the main question
is
there has to be something at stake
in every story that any of us are gonna
you know you're the ancient tribal
storyteller and you've said do you all
have a minute i've got a story to tell
you and we sit around you at the fire on
the stones and you tell us the story now
we all love stories about ourselves
right that's what the tribal storyteller
tells and that's what people like about
my story is that because they're
they're the stuff in me that i know is
universal it holds up a mirror to them
and so you say if nothing happens in
your story if nothing happens to their
favorite character what's the story it's
not a story it's so if it's right yeah
and then what you as the writer do is
mess with them they couldn't survive if
they lost their
partner if the partner left them that's
the single most driving force in their
life they couldn't function if they lost
their sobriety
that's what causes them to panic they
couldn't stand it if something happened
to one of their kids
lean on them and then you can keep just
closing your eyes and studying them you
know if you have two characters who hate
each other put them in an elevator that
breaks down you know and see how they
react
figure out what they can't stand to lose
and then you've got us on the sea oh
please don't let that happen no
don't make that what's gonna happen
you